in this video we are going to talk about  an important device in networking called  a network interface card or NIC so  before we talk about that I want to give  you an example of how humans communicate  now imagine we have three different  people John Bob and Mary how do they  talk when you are talking you are using  your mouth so you are transmitting  information using the mouth and the  other person is receiving the  information through their ears now how  do computers you know talk or listen  they have a device called network  interface card which acts as the ear and  the mouth of the computer so that's how  computers talk through the network  interface card